(arcade music)
- All right, so today we're gonna be
watching a Jubilee video.
- This is a Jubilee video.
- All right, you guys seem to like
the Jubilee video that we did last week.
- "Odd one out" by Jubilee.
- Jubilee is doing an
episode on Cody Ko fans.
I got so many tweets that
were like, do you know
about this?
Do you know about this?
And all I gotta say to that is,
shh, shut the (beep) up.
Just shut up.
You'll see.
- [Host] We brought
together seven Cody Ko fans.
- I'm a Cody Ko fan.
- And I'm a Cody Ko fan.
Actually I am Cody Ko.
And I'm not a fan.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
- [Host] One is actually the real Cody Ko.
- [Cody] None of the fans
know Cody is in the game.
- [Host] If the group
discovers the liar is,
they'll split a cash prize.
If Cody survives, he
wins the entire prize.
With Mics and cameras off.
Can the fans find who's the "Odd One Out"?
- All right, my fake name is Josh Miller.
What's my background?
I'm a rabid fan of Cody Ko.
- My strategy for the
game is to be friendly,
but also to put pressure on people.
- I'm honestly looking
out for a Noel Miller fan.
A Noel Miller fan could easily
know enough general information.
- I am a Cody Ko fan, but
I don't know that much
about Cody Ko.
I literally Googled Cody Ko facts,
just to make sure that
I knew enough about him.
- I love Cody Ko and
hopefully he sees this video.
- I cannot tell you how freaked out I was.
When I found out that Cody
had reviewed my video.
- Yeah, I'm gonna judge a
book by its cover right now.
This is the girl that's
not in it for love.
- I think I'm gonna win.
It's either that or getting
kicked out in the first round.
- I'm gonna be reciting.
His, my, his, my favorite videos of his,
all the best memes.
"You're old dude".
That's a good one.
I can't wait.
Let's go.
Oh (beep)
what do I say?
Hey, lol.
(messages pinging)
Hey (chuckles).
I don't know what to say.
- Ashley's Bitmoji is sus
as hell, I don't like Joe.
Something's off.
- Okay. What do we even ask?
What do we even ask?
- Where is everyone from?
I'm gonna say, where is everyone from?
That's fine, right?
That's, was I too forward?
Did I jump into it real fast?
Hey, hey, where are you from?
That's what that felt like.
Hey, lol so where you guys from?.
- No one cares where we're from.
No one cares where we're from.
No one's gonna remember.
- Oh, Mat is from Serbia?
I instantly trust him with my life.
- Cool. I'm from LA.
Oh, (beep) someone else is from LA.
Dammit!
I gotta think of a neighborhood.
Oh no.
- Did y'all watch real bros?
- Did y'all watch real bros? Yep.
First one and a half seasons.
- What is real bros?
Oh, no.
I'm a fake fan.
- I found him through the podcast.
Okay, okay.
- Real bros was so funny.
- I've put in a few questions,
but I haven't got a response back yet.
(crickets chirping)
(keyboard typing)
- Did anyone else have
TMG as their top podcast
for Spotify wrapped?
- Yeah, I did lol.
- Oh my God.
They all had the podcast.
I'm just gonna lie.
- I'm so nervous that I don't speak.
I'm not speaking anything.
Truly their mindset.
Only the first episode.
- See dude, that is a good question.
'Cause "Trillionaire Mindset".
That is like something that he produced
but not a lot of people know about.
- Honestly, I think I
slept on a vid of his,
is the that's cringe valentines edition.
- There's cringe to be had.
- Okay, Josh has been super quiet.
Maybe it's Josh.
- I don't know.
I literally have no
idea who the fake fan is
at this point.
It literally could be anyone.
Could be me.
- Oh (beep), was that a bad thing to say?
Is that too obvious?
- Okay, Mat just said fantastic vid.
- I think I'm fitting in right now.
Maybe I just don't say anything.
I think, I think I've said my peace.
(group chatters)
(bell rings)
- I wasn't too aggressive.
I blended in just fine.
I was a little bit boring.
- So it's between Ashley and Josh.
But I'm gonna wait on Ashley.
And I'm gonna go with Josh.
- I'm gonna say Ameer.
But I'm like, eh, not really suspicious.
Like, hardcore of anyone right now.
- Probably going to vote out Ashley.
- I'm gonna vote for Mat on this round.
- I think I'm gonna vote for Joe.
Actually no I shouldn't.
I shouldn't vote for Joe.
I'm gonna vote for McKim.
- I'm gonna vote for Josh though.
His Bitmoji isn't ironic enough.
- I don't think I'm gonna
get voted off this round.
Honestly. I think Joe
is, I'm voting for Joe.
Joe's acting real weird, okay.
Later Joe.
- The person eliminated this round is
- Don't say Josh
Josh.
(buzzer sounds)
(Cody laughs)
(Group chatters)
- How, I was totally normal.
Why?
Was saying that season two was worth it?
Was that not normal?
Or was it the Valentines cringe comment?
Maybe I should have said nothing.
Maybe I didn't say enough.
Maybe I wasn't fast enough.
I don't know.
I played the game the way I came to play,
and I'll stand by that.
I'm proud of my performance.
I wanted to win.
(clock ticking)
(Messages pinging)
- Okay, so now I like this better.
Just observing.
Although they're all fans now.
So I might just go rogue and just be like.
(Keyboard clattering)
- What the (beep) is going on with Joe?
Why is he being so weird?
- Any Mr.Struggles in Chat?
Only, I feel like my
favorite Cody Ko joke,
is Mr. Struggle.
- Guy number three that you definitely
shouldn't date, court or
marry, is Mr. Struggle.
(Laughing)
- This is.
- I've got my God damn struggles.
- Yeah
- I've been Mr. Struggle before.
(beep) you guys.
- Do you guys consider yourselves godlike?
- Would you describe
yourself as a godly man?
- Yeah, I'm constantly at
the top of the Leaderboard.
Any video game.
Always.
- Godlike.
- I'm constantly top of the leaderboard.
Any reference understanders?
- Okay. Oddly, I guess as well.
Does he have any traditions?
- Oh my God, they asked about age.
They asked about age.
This is the test.
- Cody is around 30, 85.
Not funny.
Date of birth, a very long time ago, aha.
- You guys see the new tattoo he got?
- His new tattoo?
I don't follow on Instagram.
- Yo, did you guys see
the new tattoo he got?
Which one are you talking about?
- No, what was it?
- Okay, so Joe's calling people out.
He's saying, did you see the new tattoo?
And then Mat said, no, what was it?
And he said, wow, dude.
Wow.
So are you a fan?
Or what's good bro?
- Wait Joe, what is this new tattoo?
- This new tattoo.
He just got it right?
- I'm sus.
- Joe.
- Whaaat?
- Sus my (beep), he just called me sus
for not knowing about his new tattoo.
- Who the (beep) knows
about his new tattoo?
Everyone's freaking out
about the new tattoo.
- It was on the, yeah,
it was on the TMG bro.
Come on, am I the only one who knows this?
- Yeah. He tattooed a smiley face
on his leg while he was drunk.
(bell rings)
Yeah, I did.
Unfortunately.
No, it's actually sick though.
Um, I was gonna show you.
But it's probably not
appropriate for a Jubilee video.
Hey, here's my upper thigh.
- How would I know about his new tattoo?
Also, they said that apparently
the new tattoo was actually
in the newest episode
of the podcast.
Super easy for a fake Cody Ko fan to just,
watch the most recent episode.
I'm voting out Joe.
- Fiona's gonna be my vote.
- It's sus that Joe was
saying someone's sus,
'cause we were all just chilling.
But you know what, Ameer, again.
He was more passive than active.
- Yeah, I think I'm gonna vote for Ameer.
- I mean Ameer could also
just be like a Noel stand.
- I'm gonna place my vote for Joe.
- Who do I think is getting
voted out this round?
I don't know, I'll just
take a guess, Ameer.
And then if he gets
voted out, I can be like
oh I did something right today.
- And the person eliminated this round.
In round two.
Is.
Ameer.
it's gonna be me.
- (Gasp) No!
(buzzer)
- Wait, I got it right.
I did it.
I did something good today.
Let's go!
What's up!
(chuckles)
(slap)
- You will all have two
minutes to think of.
And caption the picture
that is going to be posted
in the group chat.
- I'm laughing at everyone
that's downloading this picture
to their hard drive right now.
- How do I even caption this?
- What am I supposed to do?
Cause everyone is gonna be like,
when the app is frictionless,
'cause we are all tired of that.
- Frictionless, frictionless,
frictionless, frictionless.
- Let's see what you got Joe.
What does that say?
My face when Cody Ko makes
another useless podcast.
(Deep voice) Dude
Hey bro, this is Cody and (beep) you.
Let's see what you got Fiona.
Just drank some (beep) powder.
Okay, yeah.
- Camu powder?
Oh dude, you're drinking (beep) powder?
Ugh.
- Good meme.
Solid meme.
- I don't even know if
I'm allowed to say (beep).
- Let's see Mat.
Let's see what you got Mat.
- Noel (chuckles)
- Noel Miller.
- This isn't funny (chuckles).
- That was pretty funny.
I mean, I didn't even really
get it, but it's just funny.
- Okay. It's kind of.
Okay, it's kind of funny (chuckles)
- When you're sponsored by love island.
So you don't have to pay
for the next episode.
- I like this one.
'Cause love island was
how I found Noel and Cody.
- (inaudible)
I don't get it.
Sorry McKim.
I need more love island episodes.
(beep) off.
Ashley.
When Chili decides not to
bark while you're vlogging.
Yeah, okay.
I like that one.
Okay.
That was accurate.
Nice.
- Right Chili?
- I know.
(dog barks)
Memes are hard.
That's what we've learned.
I can't do them either.
Like I'm being a dick.
- I will be voting for Joe.
one plus one is no longer equaling two.
- I feel like I'm just
tunnel visioning on Joe.
And Joe probably is just
like a normal Cody Ko fan.
- Powder, good one.
But also could be a recent watch.
- I am suspicious of Mat.
He just, his caption was just Noel Miller.
- I think that's a really funny meme.
But it doesn't tell me
that he knows Cody at all.
- We have a tie.
The tie is between Joe.
And Mat.
- Of course.
- Bruh.
- Of course it's between me and Joe.
(dramatic music)
I need to be specific.
I need to be very specific.
- The after.
Just.
- Uh, when you're a collegiate athlete.
When you have a 2.5 GPA.
My face when I'm not only a Dukie,
but also taking a Dookie.
Let's see if I can recreate that smile.
Me after meditating and
eating Walnut salad.
Mm, I'm gonna give that
one a meh, you know.
- Does anyone understand my deep cut?
- I feel like I'm being a hater.
- It's alright.
- I'm so done with this Walnut salad.
- You're diving in her Dms,
I'm diving in her pu- (chuckles).
We are not the same.
- See?
- Okay.
No, it's not, it's not a Cody Ko joke.
- Woo. There's a joke.
- By the way, the word
that you can't read there,
it probably says pool, right?
I'm diving in her pool.
Right?
That probably says pool.
That's what he meant right?
Pool?
- I know it's Mat, that has nothing
to do with Cody Ko my friends.
- 1000% voting for Joe.
- I will vote for Mat, once more.
- Joe's was definitely a deep cut.
And if we're just looking
for the non Cody Ko fan,
then I'm gonna go with the deep cut.
- And the person eliminated this round is,
Mat.
- What?
- Let's go!
- Mat got eliminated?
So then are you saying
the funnier meme would be
the fake fan?
Because the real fan.
Is this an insult to me somehow?
- Round three just
spiraled down so quickly.
- If everyone feels confident
that you already voted
out the mole, you can end the game now.
But if the majority has
doubts, the game will continue.
- Ashley, Fiona, me.
We're good.
I don't know about Joe.
- Okay. I still think it's Joe though.
- We can continue.
I think it's Mat, but.
- I'm so torn, okay.
- I think
- I'm sorry Fiona.
No!
- Oh, and it's over.
- I gonna be so upset.
- I wanna continue man.
- I wanna continue
- It's over.
It's over.
Time to reveal myself.
- If the color that shows up is green.
You all win.
If it's red.
The fake fan is still in the game.
And you all lost.
I'm so stressed, hope we win.
- Three.
Please be red and please be Joe.
Please be red.
Two.
- Please be Joe.
Please be red.
Please be Joe.
- Let's go.
I knew it.
- It's not Joe
- It's not Joe?
- I knew it bro.
- It was not Joe.
- I'm so smart.
- I knew it was Mat.
- Joe had me bamboozled.
Dude, How is it not Joe?
Yes (chuckles).
- The game is over and
the Cody Ko fans have won.
Please turn on your Zoom cameras in.
Three.
Two.
One.
(beeping)
- Hi.
- Ameer.
- Hey everybody.
- Hi.
- Are you saying hi or are
you saying you're the mole?
- Hey.
- Hi.
(group exclaims)
- Wait what?
- I knew he was in here.
- Oh my God, dude.
- Cody Ko is in here.
- How did you guys vote me out first?
- Um (chuckles).
- Your vibe was off.
That's why we voted you out.
I had so many notes-
I was like super-
written down about you.
low key about it.
- I was like, yeah.
Oh, but that's cringe
valentines pretty funny huh?
And then you guys were like, Josh, Josh.
- Cody. Thank you for being you.
I know you hate compliments.
So, yeah.
- Honestly you're super funny.
You've brought me closer
to some of my best friends.
So just, thanks for being you
and thanks for all your content.
- Hell yeah.
Thank you.
Hey, nice to meet you all.
I appreciate it.
It was, this was fun.
- Oh man.
It is such a dream to
actually meet him and talk,
that's crazy.
- He's helped me through so many times,
like his videos so.
It means a lot to like, you
know, have this experience.
- That's really like, I'm
proud to be a Cody Ko fan.
- You won.
Oh my God.
So cool.
You guys won.
Thanks for watching "Odd One Out".
Subscribe to, me, Cody Ko.
and subscribe Jubilee of course.
And thank you Jubilee for having me.
I appreciate it.
Bye.